Jesus name
[Music]
so there is a French pro basketball
player whose jersey is in high demand
right now
is this a super tall dude he is super
well yeah he's tall yeah he's very tall
but uh is his last name hilarious
his first name's Steve so it's probably
not wow his last name is definitely not
hilarious
it's not a laughing matter
he is uh he's in the French league oh
never mind I've been seeing this dude
that's like
on highlight reels I think it's from
France and he's like seven four yeah
there is a dude yeah people love that
guy too yeah
some of these guys crazy this guy is uh
yeah he's he is good though but um
everybody wants his jersey and you're
about to find out why his last name is
bukaki or something hey whoa whoa whoa
whoa almost
front holding fat oh you fast that's
right I have seen that that's sick
the real origins or did he change his
name and because then he's a [ __ ]
Legend So that also sounds like like one
of those fake Asian names you know yeah
yeah [ __ ] me long or whatever yeah
something wrong something wrong yeah
so this dude
um he's actually
his uh paternal grandfather I believe is
Chinese
whoa it is yeah yeah it says his
grandfather originally left China for
France his mother is African
um yeah so it's in his grandfather's yo
we should get his jersey his jersey oh
you fat dude so he's part Chinese that's
cool ethnically
oh what's that he's ethnically part
Chinese uh no he's well yeah he is
because of his grandfather Yeah
I'm trying to find what team he's on but
I can't find that I did see a [ __ ]
photo of him holding the jersey and said
oh you fat and I was like no way yeah
yeah now I kept on scrolling but yeah
now this is like a for real name I'm
like holy I mean hoe you [ __ ] the
Metropolitan oh you [ __ ] yeah Steve
Stevie wait a spelling his name five
different ways but yeah Steve hold you
fat Steve that's dope what a [ __ ]
funny name dude just Steve
it's felt very correctly really okay
yeah
h-o-y-o-u-f-a-t with you
because it could have been like and in
fact f-189 wait why the y-o-u that's
that's wild that's like a little too
like it's cool on the nose that's two on
there that's it that's a troll I've done
that just I don't know if his grandpa
did it like sometimes it's like it's
actually why you but then the guy making
the Jersey is like nah this is too good
well you know how when you immigrate and
you go you have to like fill the format
you could spell your name however the
[ __ ] you want right that's how we got
done and you have no control over it so
uh you know my dad has like seven
brothers and sisters they all immigrated
at different times from different ports
some came in through San Francisco some
came in through La whatever we all have
the same Chinese last name but there's
three different quans in our family like
with o there's one with the g-u-a-n and
there's one with r's Kwan there's
another one I think with the o or with
the Q oh but what what Quan does uh
Burton bort have
Swan uh Swan
board is my new favorite so it's just
whatever random American working at the
immigration office that's like that
sounds like Q then it goes to that or
you know just whatever they hear that's
exactly what happened dude yeah my
Vietnamese last name is l y so my
parents actually their last name is l y
but then coming here it was pretty much
turned to l-e wow
it's supposed to be lie or it's supposed
to be still still leave with l y oh this
is a great Jersey
good colors come on dude
Steve with two e's with two e's yeah you
should do that I it's a great it's great
I don't think I can pull it off that's
too funny it's kind of hard all right
you know I'm just gonna see how we can
go in there that's badass it's pretty
badass metropolitans oh you fat
because everyone's gonna want one do you
think women will be mad
they can't that last name only
but thanks for uh bringing that up
that's the battle would you keep
Lionheart or would you go to uh you oh
you fat yeah I was hoping you'd say the
right answer
so long Lionheart because you actually
have you actually have a really cool
last name already so it's like I will
always keep my last name
selling his jersey yet
what if um some the guy you were
marrying had an even cooler one lion
balls
you want to take line balls then you
gotta merge it
um it's almost there well not like
Dragon heart if that was like your
counterpart Jermaine Dragonheart we
would combine it together maybe heart
heart heart
dragon lion what are we getting at so
you guys uh want to get this jersey
let's get this yeah I don't even think
they made it yet someone's some guy in
downtown is making it right now yeah
yeah you guys make it right now it's
probably like a you gotta like walk up
and buy it from a textile dude yeah can
you spell this out hunting for it but
yeah they're sports teams just as lame
as ours you know like Phoenix Suns like
what the [ __ ] the Sun the Metropolitan
the Metropolitan like the [ __ ] do you
like that name the Metropolitan that's
oh they're the Metropolitan yeah what's
another one then
uh let's look up some French French
sports sports names worst Pro Sports
names how about that I mean they'll all
be worse
I don't know because they're French I
got it [ __ ] you bought one yep
whoa it looks kind of cool too where'd
you where'd you get it how much is it
I'll tell you off camera because we're
not paying us
damn I'm about to get one oh you fat
also into the group show okay yeah yeah
yeah
Joe's gonna buy one immediately he's not
hard to find them I guess if Steve gets
it though it's like his name's also
Steve it's like way cooler yeah oh it's
not as cool for us grab it as well dude
their names are stuff that I can't even
like say
what does that mean I don't know it
looks like a ball with a mountain on it
so along with the mountain on it yeah
their names are boring yeah just like
ours oh the BCM
look what the [ __ ] is a Laker what was
the Laker the jdad of sorts like gold
digger types wasn't that because of the
they used to be located by the Great
Lakes yeah but what is a Lakers still I
just remember the Lakers I need chickens
[ __ ] enthusiasts of uh bodies of
water that are not connected to rivers
or oceans but now I'm an avid Laker you
see like that that's what it sounds like
yeah that's like the 49ers it's like how
how much time do you think we have until
[ __ ] Asians get mad about what how
are you fat being used in a comical way
do you think people are gonna be mad
about that the team moved to Minneapolis
in 1947 his name was changed to the
Lakers to reflect the Minnesota state
nickname land of 10 000 lakes that same
year the Lakers acquired Georgia make
him a little came with a little the
Lakers Los Angeles Lakers history from
Minneapolis we have like two lakes in
L.A and like like yeah and like and the
other ones are secret that only like
gated communities know about yeah oh
yeah you know about those ones you go up
there you're like there's a [ __ ] Lake
up here yeah and the house is all around
them
those legs are dope there's a bunch of
little ones next to each other right
yeah like you go up in the mountains and
you'll like when you take a helicopter
tour you're like La is mostly Lakes
and they never said [ __ ] and they never
said [ __ ] God damn it we are the Lakers
rich people are good at keeping secrets
of their communities dude the private
beaches thing is a [ __ ] joke yeah
that's a scam dude scam I go on their
Beach dude I'll give a [ __ ] don't knock
the Zuck you don't want the beach dude
yeah you don't know the beach it's jerky
that's what I say so yeah this um this
player I don't even know if he's good
I'm sure he must be like well I just saw
him miss a three right yeah yeah yeah
that should be the definitive thing
right now any [ __ ] bounced off the
rim but do you think um him having a
name like this would help his chances to
be drafted to NBA in my league yeah but
I don't think we have very much I think
I think that when you get more attention
regardless you either step up or you
don't you know what I mean if there's
suddenly like more natural viral
attention yeah I think it's gonna put a
different type of pressure on him as a
player and maybe he could step up to
utilize it like when Lynn sanity became
thing he [ __ ] started carrying it it
became like automatic even though like
you know that was literally kind of like
almost a quick blip it was like two
years yeah but it went to like all the
way to like [ __ ] he was like an Asian
dude on Time Magazine type [ __ ] you know
so didn't he get kind of like [ __ ] up
a little bit over that a little bit but
like when it was happening when he was
riding that wave that [ __ ] was just
automatic he would just go in and just
go you know anything my family came
together for yeah a lot of families were
into that [ __ ] but like did he get
depressed after like something like died
down
I feel like he was like not he said he
couldn't he felt like he it was mostly
mental form like he just felt like he
didn't belong in the NBA for a while
and then
his performance started showing that so
he he talked about it like postal
insanity and like hearing about how he
was like traded from one team to another
constantly I think that like messed with
him a little bit and now he's playing
like in another country Taiwan he had
all the ability to play in the NBA like
he could have really hung but I think it
was the mental side of that like which
playing in Taiwan is not bad by any
means right they got a good like thing
going and I think he's playing with his
brother now too in Taiwan or something
like that right making so much money do
you guys remember when tiger like like
late 90s when tiger was about to win
like I think there was what the [ __ ] is
it US Open one whatever it is whatever
the one is the PGA Wimbledon it was such
a big deal that at my school like the
teachers like like stopped class and
like pulled out the [ __ ] roll away
team all the way TV like history in the
making yeah it was pretty it was really
cool they'll probably do the same yeah
transferred over to the states
I had the Chinese Teachers so many
people are going to be rooting for that
though right it like You're Gonna Want
whole you fat to do well so that they
constantly have to say oh you fat like
the audience is chanting his name yeah
so like it's there's I think it's gonna
be tough pressure on one end but at the
same time like it's not like it's not
like his [ __ ] father was Michael
Jordan type pressure right it's like
your last name's oh you fat and I'm
really like I'm a fan of any kind of
amalgamation of so many different
cultures That You Don't See too often
like this is what he said he said uh he
said uh Chinese people don't like to mix
marriages I'm black it's a Chinese name
so it's not easy to talk about that
but that's it I'm proud of my name I'm
proud of who I am I'm proud of my dad
and my mom that's tight I like this dude
that attitude he's like I'm a holy fat
for Life dude oh you fat for life
forever and any hoes out there that want
to be all you fast as well holla at you
boy I swear on my name is a hoe you fat
I swear oh my God
[Music]
foreign